bom dia nesta conferência eu pretendo
abordar o tema mulheres com deficiência
transpondo barreiras na geração do
conhecimento e pretendo fazê lo a partir
de um referencial teórico de uma base
conceitual assim como a partir da minha
própria trajetória pessoal e
profissional
ao falarmos sobre esse assunto aqui
apresentado
são levados em conta dois parâmetros que
podem coexistir em uma mesma pessoa
ser mulher e ter uma deficiência
esses dois verbos distintos que eu
utilizei ser e te apontam a forma como
esses dois parâmetros devem ser
considerados na verdade a deficiência
não define a mulher em sua totalidade
aliás cada um de nós pode se fazer essa
pergunta não é o que realmente me
definir uma mulher é definida pelo
conjunto dos seus papéis sociais pelo
conjunto das suas realizações das suas
atuações e não apenas por uma das suas
características que pode vir a ser uma
deficiência
essa é a razão pela qual em pleno século
21 nós evitamos dizer ou não dizemos
mais mulheres deficientes porque elas de
fato não são deficientes
enquanto mulheres então nós já podemos
digamos assim dar adeus ou abandonar as
propostas e iniciativas que
equivocadamente e sejam voltadas à
mulheres deficientes porque elas não
existem porque infelizmente nós já
estamos em um outro tempo próximo
nós podemos pensar então quais são os
reais impactos de uma deficiência na
vida dos indivíduos que possuem as
pessoas com deficiência ao longo de suas
vidas e no seu dia a dia
precisam transpor algumas barreiras e
não são decorrentes das suas próprias
limitações físicas sensoriais
intelectuais ou motoras mas sim
barreiras que são decorrentes de
ambientes que não são concebidos de uma
forma universal ou seja ambientes que
não são concebidos de modo a se garantir
a equiparação de condições e
oportunidades para todas as pessoas
próximo interessante notarmos que a
deficiência na verdade é muito
importante para a própria evolução da
humanidade porque a presença de pessoas
com deficiência em lugares variados nos
mais variados contextos favorece a
concepção a criação de ambientes mais
universais mas urais e portanto mais
acolhedores
da mesma forma a deficiência favorece a
desconstrução de alguns paradigmas que
já são pré estabelecidos por exemplo se
não houvesse pessoas cegas no mundo
poderia se admitir a idéia de que seria
impossível ler sem enxergar o que não é
verdade próximo
eu posso falar hoje sobre esse tema com
vocês a partir de uma abordagem bastante
experience ao porque eu falo aqui pra
vocês a partir de um lugar de quem
vivencia essa condição de ser mulher e
ter uma deficiência isso porque eu tenho
deficiência visual congênita tenho
cegueira total e congênita e possa dizer
que essa deficiência e tem proporcionado
ao longo da vida experiências muito
significativas muito valiosas
e ele ah eu não
teria tido se eu enxergasse a cegueira
tenha aberto pra mim oportunidades muito
ricas que certamente eu não teria se eu
enxergasse próximo por favor
uma dessas oportunidades é o contato com
a leitura e escrita musical em braille é
uma experiência realmente apaixonante e
fascinante
já quando criança eu fui alfabetizada
por meio do sistema braille e e eu pude
criar um vínculo de muita intimidade com
esse sistema de leitura e escrita porque
ele foi parte crucial da minha formação
acadêmica da minha formação escolar
o braille foi pra mim uma fonte muito
importante de apropriação do próprio
conhecimento essa razão pela qual
estabelece um vínculo de tanta
intimidade e por que não dizer até de
amor com o sistema braille e
paralelamente eu pude também por meio da
formação musical que eu recebi em piano
que foi o instrumento que eu escolhi
também aprender a ler partituras por
meio do sistema braille
então eu tive acesso a experiência de
como eu tenho dito tocar para tocar
isto é poder tocar com as mãos uma
partitura para tocá-la ao instrumento
e essa experiência de tocar para tocar
fez toda a diferença na minha vida e foi
o que me motivou a fazer da musicografia
braille o meu objeto de pesquisa foi o
que me motivou a me tornar uma
pesquisadora nessa área a começar pelo
mestrado e pelo doutorado que eu defendi
aqui no instituto de artes da unicamp
com o apoio da fapesp
abordando este tema próximo por favor eu
considero a pesquisa relacionada a
musicografia braille
só 3 psp
as diferentes isto é existem três
recordes possíveis dentro da pesquisa em
música grafia braille o primeiro recorte
é o estudo sobre o ensino eo aprendizado
da musicografia braille
este recorte envolve por um lado o
estudo sobre o quanto os educadores
musicais estão ou não estão ainda
instrumentalizados para capacitarem seus
alunos cegos no aprendizado da
musicografia braille
por outro lado este recorte também
envolve as vias de acesso que os alunos
cegos estão tendo ao aprendizado do
código musical em bray o segundo recorde
possível é o estudo sobre a produção de
partituras em braille que envolve as
metodologias e tecnologias para
transcrição de partituras e à formação
de repertório musical de obras
transcritas para braille o terceiro
recorde possível é o estudo sobre os
processos cognitivos envolvidos na
leitura musical em braile
esse recorte é particularmente
interessante nós podemos notar que as
pessoas cegas ao interagirem com uma
partitura elas estabelecem um contato
bastante ativo com essa partitura se
comparadas ao contato estabelecido pelas
pessoas
videntes diante de uma partitura uma
pessoa vidente
olha a segui lá o que está escrito e
reproduz quase que simultaneamente no
instrumento no seu instrumento musical
aquilo que ele lê uma pessoa cega por
sua vez diante de uma partitura
ela lê a partitura com as mãos mas ela
não tem a mesma dimensão global que a
visão da as pessoas vidência
pessoas que enxergam então essa pessoa
cega diante de uma partitura precisa e
um exercício mental de abstração com o
por todos os elementos dessa peça antes
de executá la ao instrumento
então essa é a razão pela qual as
pessoas cegas estabelecem com a
partitura particularmente um contato uma
relação bastante ativa que requer todo
esse processo de abstração e essa é a
razão pela qual parece ser tão
importante estudar e aprofundar os
processos cognitivos envolvidos na
leitura e escrita musical em braille que
contribui também para o estudo dos
processos cognitivos na leitura e
escrita musical de maneira geral
então esses três recordes de pesquisa
sobre a musicografia braille tem me
acompanhado na minha trajetória como
pesquisadora e eu posso dizer
então como mulher com deficiência e
também pesquisadora que nós mulheres com
deficiência precisamos lutar pela nossa
legitimidade próximo favor de fato nós
mulheres com deficiência
precisamos buscar a legitimação dos
nossos diferentes papéis sociais o que
significa que nós precisamos lutar para
sermos reconhecidas não pela nossa
deficiência mas sim pela nossa atuação
nós precisamos buscar ser reconhecidas
nos nossos diferentes papéis como
pesquisadoras ou como professoras ou
talvez como mães ou como educadoras são
os nossos papéis as nossas as nossas
atuações que nos definem que definem
quem nós somos perante a sociedade
da mesma forma nós devemos procurar
atuar como protagonistas dos nossos
projetos de vida
responsabilizando os pelas nossas
decisões pelas nossas escolhas e assim
sendo protagonistas na condução e no
curso da nossa própria história
muito obrigado